[Musique]
[Rires]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de mode d'emploi avec un focus sur les
métiers de l'agriculture
sans oublier notre volet consacré à la
formation sans plus tarder voici le
sommaire que ce soit dans des
exploitations comme à saint cyr l'école
dans des fermes pédagogiques comme à
rambouillet les métiers sont nombreux
dans le secteur de l'agriculture
reportage au sein du premier
démonstrateur d'agriculture urbaine et à
la bergerie nationale
nous avons poussé les portes de
l'institut supérieur de l'environnement
l'établissement situé à trappes permet
de se former aux métiers agricoles avec
une dimension développement durable
avec près de 1000 exploitations
agricoles les yvelines sont le deuxième
territoire agricole d'île de france avec
le salon international de l'agriculture
qui se déroule jusqu'au 4 mars porte de
versailles à paris
tout le monde a les yeux rivés en ce
moment sur ce secteur nous nous sommes
justement intéressé aux métiers liés à
l'agriculture
on en dénombre environ 80 la plupart
d'entre eux se déroule évidemment en
extérieur et direction justement les
ferme en ville à saint cyr l'école
nous irons ensuite à la bergerie
nationale à rambouillet c'est des
haricots verts nains qui arrive à peu
près de cette taille là sont vraiment
extra fins sans fil depuis un peu plus
d'un an
romain s'occupe des différentes
productions maraîchères sur ce terrain
de trois hectares et demi
asperges fraises tomates cerises ont
encore framboise inauguré en 2014 ce
lieu les ferme en ville à saint cyr
l'école est un ancien dépôt de terre de
remblai il comporte aujourd'hui
plusieurs parties des ateliers
pédagogiques des potagers pour les
particuliers et différentes cultures
hors sol ont fait ce site démonstrateur
d'agriculture urbaine sert à prouver
voilà qu'on peut qu'on peut cultiver des
fruits et légumes
dans un environnement urbain ou
périurbain ici on est sur un site où le
sol était un peu pollué donc on est
toutes en agriculture hors sol avec des
vagues dépôt des jardinières et donc
ensuite on a d'irrigation qui arrive on
va là directement qui est contrôlé et
qui arrive directement au goutte à
goutte dans les plantes chaque année
environ 10 tonnes de fruits et légumes
sont produits et sont vendus
principalement à la ferme de gally
titulaire d'un bts commercial
international romain a très vite changé
de voie un choix qu'il ne regrette pas
le travail extérieur la nature les
plantes
voilà connaître un peu les végétaux les
maladies les nutriments les nuisibles et
auxiliaires et c est tout un tas de
choses à connaître pour gérer un site
comme celui ci il faut bien s'organiser
il faut aussi faire avec les aléas
climatiques qu'on a de tous les jours
aussi bien la température que
l'ensoleillement que la pluie etc
donc faut vraiment bien géré les choses
pour pas se faire déborder par la nature
et puis entretenir les végétaux et sert
à caen
[Musique]
construite sous louis saez pour
accueillir les célèbres moutons mérinos
la bergerie nationale est une ferme
pédagogique grandeur nature elle est
située à rambouillet et propose
plusieurs activités
frédéric brio bonjour vous êtes
responsable de l'équipe d'animation ici
au sein de la bergerie nationale alors
la bergerie nationale c'est combien
d'hectares à la bergerie nationale c'est
plus de presque 300 hectares qui sont
principalement des espaces pour pour les
animaux on y élève pas que des moutons
il ya toujours le troupeau mérinos
historique mais on élève principalement
des autres races de moutons qu'on
appelle les romane et surtout des vaches
laitières qui sont passés il ya quelques
années on agriculture biologique bien
combien de personnes qui travaillent ici
l'exploitation c'est à peu près quinze
personnes dont il ya cinq à six
personnes qui sont sur la production
donc pour élever les animaux gérer les
engins et les terres et voyez 7 7 à 8
personnes qui s'occupent de l'équipe
d'animation pour accueillir tous ses
visiteurs il ya vraiment des métiers
diversifiés finalement voilà tout à fait
vrai mais c'est bien c'est un peu
l'objectif de la bergerie c'est de
montrer que l'agriculteur il doit pas se
cantonner à juste dans l'idéal après il
peut il peut le faire mais mais pour
pouvoir vivre maintenant il faut
vraiment diversifié son travail
travailler la terre c'est la base et
après pouvoir l'expliquer au public aux
enfants et valoriser localement circuits
courts les produits mode bonjour vous
êtes soigneuse animalière et animatrice
ici à la bergerie nationale ça fait cinq
ans que vous travailliez ici
alors en quoi ça consiste votre métier
de soigneuse animalière et d'animatrice
alors c'est simple en fait le matin
quand j'arrive je m'occupe des animaux
moi je suis en charge des animaux
pédagogiques sont la ferme
donc j'ai un petit troupeau de chèvres
en charge chez les animaux de la
basse-cour n'ayez poules lapins cochons
elle était animatrice et bien justement
une fois que j'ai fini m'occuper de tout
ce petit monde
j'accueille
les élèves public ce ça va justement de
la maternelle jusqu'au quatrième âge et
je leur fais découvrir ce que c'est que
tu fermes et les animaux qui alors vous
avez fait quoi comme d'habitude pour
faire ce métier
alors moi j'essaie d'abord un bac
technologique agricole pour commencer ça
m'a permis justement de mettre un petit
peu chez dans l'agriculture et après
j'ai fait un bts gpn c1 gestion
protection de la nature en tant
qu'animatrice nature donc le but c'était
de faire de l'éducation à
l'environnement prévu que moi
éducation environnement pour moi ça
passe aussi par l'agriculture et là j'ai
toujours voulu travailler dans une ferme
pédagogique l'année dernière en 2017 la
bergerie nationale a accueilli 115 mille
visiteurs des métiers qui nécessitent
évidemment des formations bien précise
il faut savoir que l'enseignement
agricole offre des formations à tous les
niveaux alors à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'institut
supérieur de l'environnement situé à
trappes propose notamment un bts
agricole gestion et protection de la
nature
reportage c'est à trappes est implanté
l'institut supérieur de l'environnement
cette école du management de
l'environnement et du développement
durable propose des formations de bac +2
à bac +5
depuis 25 ans en fait institut super de
l'environnement des livres trois
diplômes différents
le bts gpn qui a un bac + 2 qui est le
brevet technicien supérieur agricole
gestion et protection de la nature qui a
un diplôme de l'état en fait spécialisé
sur tous les métiers très proche de la
nature
on a un deuxième diplôme qui est un
bachelor en environnement qui est plus
pour les techniciens environnementaux
qui travailleront en entreprise sur
toutes les problématiques hills qui sont
identifiés et enfin on a un troisième
diplôme qui a un master en management de
l'ingénierie et du droit de
l'environnement
le cadran bonjour bonjour vous êtes
enseignant en écologie ici alliès vous
êtes également à le référent du diplôme
bts gpn alors bts gpn ça veut dire bts
gpn c'est un brevet de technicien
supérieur agricole en gestion et
protection de la nature
alors il consiste en quoi alors ce bts
gpn il consiste à former des étudiants à
la gestion et à la valorisation des
espaces naturels
alors quel type de matière on retrouve
dans ce diplôme alors dans ce diplôme on
retrouve
de l'écologie l'écologie fondamentale on
est vraiment sur la science les
collégiens n'est pas du tout sur la
politique on leur apprend aussi à faire
des animations nature à faire la
valorisation de territoire il ya tout un
aspect aussi deux sorties sur le terrain
oui j'allais dire voilà les cours
théoriques exactement il faut absolument
les amener sur le terrain pour les
confronter à s'était injustement tout ce
qui est génial écologique à pouvoir les
amener aussi à identifier des espèces
nous sommes à la réserve naturelle de
saint quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui les élèves de l'institut
supérieur de l'environnement sont de
sortie pour mettre en pratique ce qu'ils
ont appris
[Musique]
arthur bonjour bonjour est ce que tu
peux nous dire ce que vous êtes en train
d'observer avec vos jumelles donc là on
est sur la réserve de saint quentin en
yvelines
là j'étais en train de regarder un bon
team qui se trouve là bas ainsi qu'un
corbeau rocky encore faire sécher s'est
elle une des choses qui me qui m'a plu
dans le bts c'est que certes on a des
cours théoriques mais on a un plus c'est
qu'on a des cours pratiques en fait donc
on va aller sur le terrain mettre en
pratique tout ce qu'on a appris en cours
donc là par exemple
la semaine dernière nous avons appris à
reconnaître les principales dix
principaux d'oiseaux donc on peut
trouver sur la réserve saint quentin est
donc aujourd'hui on est venu les
observer par nous mêmes avec nos
jumelles et notre livre de ta
détermination et donc ben c'est
intéressant
liona bonjour bonjour vous êtes en 2e
année bachelor environnement à
l'institut supérieur de l'environnement
pourquoi vous avez choisi cette
formation est bien parce que boulogne
ronis ces évidences on va dire et puis
on évolue quotidiennement dans
l'environnement et donc ça me paraissait
ça m'a toujours paru en fait logique
décès trouver des solutions face aux
problématiques actuelles
alors est ce que vous savez ce que vous
allez faire après ce après ce bachelor
vous est-ce que vous avez déjà une idée
précise du métier que vous l'exercez g
j'ai plein d'idées se dessine
progressivement j'ai un domaine disons
que c'est beau et plein d'idées près
faut que j'aime être en connexion et
puis on verra au fur et à mesure oui
donc l'humanitaire mais peint
l'international me parle un domaine
spécifique à l'environnement c'est peut
être aussi bien traitement des eaux
encore les déchets dans le monde
pourquoi pas chaque année liesse e
accueille entre 150 et 200 étudiants à
la fin de leur cursus plus de 80 %
d'entre eux sont embauchés dans les six
mois voilà vous en savez désormais plus
sur ces et métiers verts voici donc ce
qu'il faut retenir
si vous voulez devenir maraîchers comme
romain il faut être en possession
minimum dans ces apps et agricoles en
début de carrière vous toucherez le smic
évolution possible dans ce métier être
chef d'equipe la qualité indispensable
être flexible au niveau des horaires
puisque à certaines périodes de l'année
bien sûr le rythme est plus soutenu dans
notre premier sujet vous avez pu
également découvrir mode mode qui est et
soigneuse animalière et animatrice à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet alors
pour exercer ce métier il faut être
titulaire par exemple d'un bts agricole
gestion et protection de la nature
concernant la rémunération les débutants
touchent le smic soit environ 1170 euros
net après plusieurs années d'expérience
vous pourrez devenir chef soigneur
le petit plus dans ce métier aimer le
contact avec le public
cette émission touche bientôt à sa fin
mais avant voyons ensemble les
rendez-vous liés
l'emploi qui vous attendent la cité des
métiers de saint quentin en yvelines
organise un atelier le mercredi 7 mars
entre atelier intitulé vous recherchez
un stage préparer votre entretien
c'est de 14 heures à 16 heures il faut
s'inscrire au 01 34 82 82 61 maintenant
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur le
métier de développeur web alors bien sûr
vous pouvez regarder en replay notre
mode d'emploi consacré il y a deux
semaines à ce thème et puis vous pourrez
aussi vous rendre le jeudi 8 mars à la
cité des métiers attrape ses 2 à 14
heures à 16 heures il faut là aussi
s'inscrire au 01 34 82 82 61
et puis notez également ce rendez vous
si vous êtes à la recherche d'un emploi
le jeudi 29 mars 20 quentin en yvelines
organise en piste pour l'emploi un
événement qui aura lieu de 10h à 22h
pardon au vélodrome nationale l'entrée
est gratuite mais il faut s'inscrire sur
le site internet www.skype.com voilà
c'est la fin de ce numéro à merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi 13
mars pour un nouveau mode d'emploi
consacré cette fois ci aux métiers de
l'audiovisuel
à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]